this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Thursday the 6th of
October
the joint is brought to you by
DraftKings an official sports betting
partner of the NFL listen we're taking
touchdowns big plays and even bigger
wins we got a great [__] game tonight
new customers can bet five dollars in
any NFL team to win and get 200 and free
bets if they do it's that easy everyone
can boost their winnings with DraftKings
stepped up same game parlays to make
things even sweeter you could throw down
on a step up same game Polly parlay once
per day all season long not to mention
the [__] prop bets on
DraftKings will [__] I hit the
[__] uh the 60 Second Home Run 20 to
win 78. download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now use promo code Joey
to get 203 bets when your team wins when
you place five dollars on any football
team that's called Joey only on
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NFL minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details now go download
DraftKings and go win some [__]
money the holidays are coming speaking
on the holidays unless you're Santa
Claus you're not looking forward to
dealing with the holiday mail it's
starting guys if you haven't started
preparing for the chaos of holiday
mailing and shipping you're already
[__] up stamps.com is everything you
need to make the easier it's the virtual
24 7 post office no lines no traffic no
stink no hassles it's [__]
tremendousstamps.com we've been with
them for over 10 years my wife still use
them to send boxes t-shirts hats
whatever the [__] we need to send
stamps.com gives you access to post
office and UPS shipping Services right
on your computer you're gonna save up to
30 off USPS rates and over 86 percent
off UPS all you need is your regular
computer
and a printer no special supplies or
equipment be up and running in [__]
minutes Prince official postage for any
letter any package anywhere go ahead of
the Hollywood Holiday chaos this year
get started with stamps.com sign up with
the promo code Joey for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial free
postage and a free digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
on the top of the page and then to code
Joe you'll be mailing packages just like
[__] Santa Claus to join is also
brought to you by manscape Fall is here
don't let the cobwebs collect in your
[__] unit manscape is here to keep
your pumpkin [__] patch clean and
fresh listen you got to trim your ball
here your neck hair all those [__]
hairs they create stink and confusion
manscape's performance package 4.0 has
got it all the lawnmower 4.0 body
trimmer the Wii whack a nose in the ear
trimmer that features a skin safe
technology to protect your delicate
holes they're waterproof so you can
shave in the shower and manscape even
threw in two free gifts a manscape pair
of boxes that are cute and shed travel
bags take a look at the shears 2.0 their
luxury nail grooming kit it includes
stainless steel nail cutters squeezers
and grooming scissors no more scratching
your lady in bed with that hook you have
for a toe on your foot get 20 off from
free shipping with code Joey at
manscape.com again that's 20 off from
free shipping with Coach Joey at
manscape.com manscape clears out the
leaves it's your treats on time to
[__] shine let's get this party
started on Thursday morning
foreign
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's a beautiful day it's Thursday the
6th of [__] October I'm sorry I
didn't have a podcast yesterday but I
had to work this week it was a [__]
nightmare I gotta do it again next
Thursday this was not what I signed up
for but it is what it is uh this is the
time of the year between my mother's dad
and just the holidays you know people
get a little funky I don't get funky
I just start thinking about stuff like
uh
what's going on and the other day I
swear to God
I got in the car and I was driving
somewhere and I just I saw that song
came on I Can't Go For That by all notes
and I'm like [__]
and I oh every time I hear that song it
makes me think of Ralphie May right so
I'm sitting there I'm like [__]
Ralphie's anniversary is coming up soon
and all of a sudden I'm like holy [__]
it's got to be one day this week
and I didn't even finish that [__]
thought and the Smash Brothers hit me up
yesterday check in on me how you doing
and to go can you believe Thursday is
Ralphie's five-year anniversary I was
like
what the [__]
how quick did those [__] five years
go
I still have his number in my phone I
mean I still
it's funny because I used to talk to
Ralphie my main day to talk to Ralphie I
wouldn't have I wouldn't see Ralphie for
weeks at a time but for some reason we
always connected on a [__] Saturday
morning on the road he would always call
me like he would go to bed at like two
and get up like at eight and he talked
to me in between like we'd speak for
like an hour on Saturdays and I tell him
what was going on and he'd tell me what
was going on and
it was uh it was kind of nice there was
no
Ralphie and my friendship was no fluff
you ever see like you know Matt Damon
hanging out with George Clooney and
they're giggling and everything is a
[__] riot you know it wasn't like
that with him like when I was with
Ralphie we it was just us talking [__]
smoking dope giggling about people like
he didn't take anything seriously and I
miss him I miss him as a friend
but I also miss him as a stand-up
because it was as a stand-up he was a
unique [__] guy like he was just he
was bigger than life you know he was 600
[__] pounds he did not give a [__] he
wore that uh
that belt the Elvis belt like he just
won a championship and [__] it was
hysterical those [__] leather jackets
like I'm a map that he died his wife put
up clothes to sell and I'm like who fits
in that jacket
you know like the big yellow jacket from
one of the specials and like who fits in
these [__] things like I have a 4X
leather jacket upstairs that one of his
friends gave me that used to give us
both jackets I can't wear that jacket
number one if it don't weigh 100 pounds
it don't work every time I put that
jacket on I can't [__] breathe I'm
like why am I [__] huffing and
puffing because I got a way to invest on
but Ralphie was sweet he was a great
writer
and when it came to class like he was
from Arkansas you know and
when you're in California those people
looked down on southernness I'm sorry
listen they just have a
pre a pre-existing [__] mental note
about Southerners you know when they
hear that voice and [__] they kind of
like it perks up their ears uh Gentiles
in La you know and I could tell that
always hurt him it hurt my wife my wife
was from the south and every once in a
while she would throw a little twang up
and [__] you know it was like people
looking like she's [__] and that
bothered Ralphie Ralphie knew that
people looked at him you know like a
[__] redneck and he did everything he
could in his power Ralphie reminded me a
lot of my mother because
his past came into his future
he was he grew up so poor in Arkansas he
grew up so [__] poor and so like out
of search shorts that when he got older
he wanted to make that right so
everything he did was big Ralphie didn't
buy and ate the pot he bought a pound of
pot Ralph he didn't buy 10 Edibles he
bought all of them from the store you
know Ralphie didn't get two pieces of
[__] white fish sushi I mean I was
telling my wife I remember times when we
would go to sushi Dam listen to walk in
there cost you 20. just to walk into
Sushi Daniel dropping 20. whatever you
pay for [__] sushi in this country
you walk into Sushi Dan you look at
there was two places Ralphie went to
there was one [__] place that was
Sushi Dan he turned me on to Sushi Den
and I [__] loved it but there was a
place on Beverly
that Ralphie would go to and it was
straight up Gangster millionaire
celebrities at this [__] sushi spot
from Clint Eastwood to the [__]
people from X-Men I saw so many [__]
people in there when Ralphie hit he
started going to that restaurant he
didn't camp that he had 200 000 in the
bank he was going to that restaurant
twice a day every day and when he would
walk in they would Bang a Drum and yell
like
whatever Japanese people do when you're
walking and he would look back at them
and go must be the money like [__] like
that like you would just [__] die
with him he would go in there and drop
guys no exaggeration
a thousand
like a thousand for lunch
not a hundred not two fifty a thousand
eight hundred dollar lunchtime dog 200
300 trips all those Japanese people were
walking around bowing the whole [__]
time talk we used to go to this other
place when we got into Sushi we used to
go to this other place on Santa Monica
Boulevard right in the beginning of Boys
Town [__] guys I've never ever had
Albert Hall like that place again they
just didn't give you a piece of albacore
they put like [__] onions on it and
those that little red hot Filipino
[__] spice oh my God he would eat
that [__] and we would go in there me
and Ralph he was 22 bucks all you could
eat
do you understand me and we would walk
in there and they would just look at us
mortified like you guys are gonna put us
out of business
and we would go in and kill the [__]
albacore kill it every time we go back
there was a sign only 10 pieces of
albacore a lot like every time we went
back there would be something saying you
know whatever fish we [__] took apart
but the best day we the the hostess
there her name was Ellen Helen
Helen was a hot 45 year old Japanese
chick when I say hot I mean [__] hot
and we would go in there and torment
Helen like Helen you take in the ass you
know we would just say [__] to Helen
like Helen you suck a good dick and she
didn't understand she'd go huh nothing
you look pretty today you know like we
were just tour and Ralphie would [__]
die in there
that place we destroyed that but the
best day ever we walked in there one day
and they're like we closed we closed I'm
like you're not [__] closed you're
just trying to stop the fat man's
journey and [__] and they're like no we
closed we had kitchen we had fire in
kitchen and me and Ralph were like
it's a sushi place what the [__] you
mean you had a fire you Japanese people
do not know how to do Jewish lightning
leave it to the [__] Jews if you want
to burn this plate we [__] tormented
that lady we tell her Helen come over
let's smack your ass and she'd come over
she'd let us smack her out I mean we
Tipple like 50 [__] bucks a piece but
that was Ralphie like Ralphie wasn't
into
you know man stand-up comedy has gone in
the direction where it's crazy and look
and then Ralphie kind of started that
Ralphie bought the first combat
convertible bema that was like maybe 25
of them made in the country I don't know
what he spent with his [__] thing I
don't you know
but
all these other Comics man
like there's some Comics that a classy
[__] like Gabriel Iglesias
that's a stand-up [__] I'll tell
you why he would have a party every year
for Comics it would cost Gabriel close
to thirty thousand forty thousand he
would have a ten thousand dollar polka
tournament he would buy a car
he would raffle off a big screen TV you
have no [__] idea
and Ralphie had the same heart you know
Ralphie I mean he paid for Mercy's crib
I can't tell you how many times I would
call Ralphie or Ralph I don't have a
dime in my pocket and I got two flat
tires and he would go tell me what store
you want to take it to have him call me
and I'll give him my credit card without
even asking guys without even asking
never embarrass me out in public like
hey you know our journey is friends went
a long [__] time and the funny thing
about Ralphie was when I met a
Brownfield I mean everybody knows this I
was pretty much homeless and Ralphie
wasn't doing any better Ralphie just had
an apartment and he was you know Ralph
he knew how to do gigs way before me he
knew the ins and outs of County but
I missed my afternoons with him man
comedy chain like comedy changed for me
so many times it went from me and when
you get to La you just want to be
noticed and and just have some spots and
for people to like you you know and him
and I would sit together every [__]
I'd go over there about 11 and we'd
start writing stupid jokes and then we
put together our chains to figure out
what the [__] we're gonna eat for lunch
and some days he had it some days I had
it it was a beautiful
beautiful friendship from 98
it was really beautiful he he gave me
that family life like I always tell
people in L.A you miss the family he
filled that in
he [__] filled that in so much that I
was like
and he took care of me I remember him
being poor as [__]
and we would have like these little
pseudo barbecues every Sunday I would
bring a pack of chicken
Josh Wolf would bring Wings you know it
was just guys just staying alive doing
the best they could it was beautiful and
I still remember no matter how broke he
was every time we had a barbecue he
would give Josh Wolf a bag of candy like
he would go by [__] Ralphie May candy
Ralph made it just didn't buy a bar or
Hershey's Ralphie May bought a bag of
Hershey's so he would buy it for him but
when Josh would come over he would
always give him a bag of candy for his
kids I mean it was just
Josh talks about it I talk about it Doug
Stanhope talks about it when we lived on
that little Hollywood Road guys we were
Beyond poor we were just poor we were
just poor like things weren't happening
people were calling their parents you
know you had to do [__] you know and
we made it like it was the it was the
best time I had being [__] poor like
he just and then he blew up like he
started blowing up but in 2005 was when
he really hit 2004.
or 2003 when I was shooting Spider-Man 2
was when that whole thing went down and
it was he went from living and the pub
guys go to somebody's apartment on a
Monday and then call him on Thursday and
he's like you're gonna come to my new
place he lived he moved from the shitty
apartment on Gardner
or Schrader that's we live Schroeder to
a [__] uh what do you call those
things when you you live in a community
like a it was like a [__] Community
you had to go through a gate and wave at
the dude and they [__] hate him
towns
they [__] that little liquid IV
little [__] Cherry tremendous get
your [__] kicking
they hated him he had Sean Rouse living
with him I'll never forget going there
for the first time
he didn't have no food in the house he
had a little bit of food
and he had furniture and [__] but right
smack in the middle of the room on the
coffee table which was gorgeous glass
coffee table he had a [__] jar with a
pound of weed in this [__] and
he would leave it first he would have
one pound and then he just started
getting two pounds three pounds so it
would be three different types of weed
in the middle of his house with a jar
and like a cookie jar like all you had
to do is open it up and take a [__]
butt and put it back that's like the
first week he hit that's that was just
that was his first [__] thing he did
he moved he bought that [__] couch
and the TV and all this [__] and he made
sure he always had three pounds of pot
in that [__] house man that was and
once he hit I was still [__] broke as
[__]
and he never held it against me
he never said aren't you picking up a
tab we were doing
400 lunches at a steakhouse me him and
Josh Wolf he would just pick us up and
go you guys want to go eat me and Josh
were like yeah we're gonna eat turkey
burgers for lunch again and he would go
now [__] the turkey burgers let me take
it down to
[__] uh it wasn't Morton's it was the
other one right in the afternoon with
crab meat and lobster tails I'd be
sitting there going nobody would [__]
believe me that's how I ate those days
it was either him or Rogan that took me
to [__] dinner it was just insane it
was insane but I'm happy I had them both
as friends I'm happy they both
understood the struggle
and I uh
I miss Ralphie you know he was [__]
great and uh just do me a favor today at
one point of the day just watch a video
of Ralphie May and laugh just for me
just to keep him alive because it's
always [__] great just to I watch one
of his videos I put on the podcast the
other night when he started with the
[__] he hated Russians the filthy
Russians I don't even know what he was
talking about you know it was he was a
beautiful it was a beautiful life
he was a beautiful comic and he was a
[__] way better friend
and it was uh you know in Hollywood and
all that whole scene you the word love
is thrown around and he's my brother and
all this [__] the people don't even call
you to check on you to see how your kids
are you know not Ralphie Ralphie called
you every week Ralphie threw you money
Ralphie you know he was just a one of a
kind dude and the people that really
knew man they always call me like
it's weird how you know people still
heard about Ralphie and and from time to
time I got a call from like the guy that
owns Nashville Club Ralphie had some
good people in his life he had like four
or five great [__] people with comedy
and with Hollywood and all that [__] you
attract these [__] maggots and he had
a bunch of those too but and I tried to
talk to him and help him but
he uh
he loved that scene I hope he's in
heaven and he's having a good day today
and that's it that's all I want to talk
about with Ralphie I didn't want to make
this a a [__] depression Fest you
know but it was [__] he had an amazing
life
he was an amazing comic and uh
very good to me man I still remember him
me being in Jersey like in a hotel room
and him calling me up one day going what
are you doing nothing he goes I'm in
Jersey with Lana I want to pick you up
and go take you to eat in your hometown
and he [__] spent the day in North
berg and went to veneeries we went to
all these places and he loved it he
loved the stories he loved all that [__]
you know half of those jokes on this
special those were us talking the
espresso joke the Cuban expresso those
and people would call me up and go Joey
aren't you gonna say something those
jokes sound like yours you dumb
[__] we sat there for an hour
trying to write a man him sure they're
gonna sound like me he didn't steal my
people always calling me up I think
Ralphie's doing one of your jokes and if
he is who gives a [__] who gives a [__]
he's not doing one of my jokes we used
to go get food at night all the time and
I would torture him at the jalapeno pop
his dog
I don't know if that [__] could
live without Jack-in-the-Box jalapeno
poppers he loved he loved jalapeno
poppers but nothing like Jack in the Box
that [__] would go and buy three
packs of those things eat two in the car
and then show up with one I purchased
some jalapeno poppers Ralphie I could
smell the Papas from the street when you
[__] Park no no I didn't I didn't eat
any I swear he would all win then you go
in the car and you saw the two empty
[__] boxes
I miss him and uh please today in any of
your [__] uh Journeys just put them
on on Sirius or whatever you're gonna
laugh your [__] he always has something
like even now five years later I'll
watch something from a stand up the one
with the yellow jacket bigger and
Blacker or something like that he was
talking some [__] about two weeks ago
one of the videos popped up on my screen
I was [__] Island I was howling and
it's like
it was the first time I had seen that
joke I said it the other day that when I
started studying headliners
per year
the headliners that were the best that I
saw that year
where Greg Geraldo and a tight second
was Ralphie May it was a tight second
and he was starting to do something that
had never seen before because he was
Genie he was a [__] smart dude in his
own way but he was doing something
towards the end
the last 20 minutes of his set he was
selling you merch without you knowing it
it was the most brilliant thing I ever
saw in my life how he sold merch he
would say I'm getting out of here in a
couple minutes but I want you to know
but I have some T-shirts and CDs you
don't have to buy them I'm not I'm just
letting you know I got them they'll be
in the back and he would go into some
other Spiel and a blank check and a
check that bounce and next thing you
know you're just buying [__] merch I
mean it was the most
brilliant [__] thing that I saw
I got a bunch of calls this week I was
laughing because uh
I mean the big controversy this week did
we controversy
guys it's getting old like all these
self-made controversies in our country
lately like it's a controversy and
nobody went to see the gay movie
you know did you hear about that that
made some gay movie and [__] bang
brothers or it's called something like
that Brothers I don't know I don't know
what it's called I just been saying
different things about it and I was uh
laughing my ass off because enough
people didn't go see it only made five
million dollars
but they got pissed off because gay
people didn't want to go see it and
straight people didn't want to [__] out
I don't know I don't know let's let's
not movie season right now if you look
at the [__] uh what these movies are
making they're not making dick there's
not a lot of movies coming out lately
the next big release is [__] black
panther too that's it we don't have a
lot of big [__] so
but the controversy was this Bang
Brothers movie
right no no no it was a movie in the at
the theaters like I think so are
brothers it don't [__] matter but I I
didn't know what was going on I just saw
a couple things about it and then I went
to the indoor softball practice last
night and there were some parents
talking about it I was listening to them
and then they mentioned the [__]
keyword in there that got me started
Judd Apple toe that's a Judd Apatow
movie okay and listen man
[Music]
I like gay men like I don't I don't mind
them like when they talk to me I [__]
love them to death I love my my friends
that are gay
the three friends that I have I called
one the other day hasn't called me back
yet Ian uh
but guys that doesn't mean I'm gonna go
and make a gay movie
you know what I'm saying like as a
director
or as a a movie buff you know why
I tell you why
I'm not gay
why would I make a movie about being gay
if I'm not gay let's discuss that
I want to make a movie about something
that I know right or wrong I mean right
you're going to do a documentary you
want to do it what do you like I like
chicken parmesan sandwiches okay we'll
do the documentary on chicken parmesan
sandwiches because that's what you
[__] know guys that's what you know
okay so if I'm gonna look into a film
like yeah you take challenges in your
career there's a challenge like you
you're a comedy guy but one day uh
somebody calls you says or you direct my
mystery and you go you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna watch not mystery the
horror show let me go look at all the
[__] uh you know yeah different
horror movies different genres who's the
really good guy like they plays music
Rob Zombie all that you know that's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna look at it and
when I take the direct this job
I'm gonna call one of my director
friends that obviously specializes in
that
and ask him if he's not busy to stop by
this set one or two days
just to give me some pointers maybe he
knows that's how I would do it but I
would always ask for help okay
why would a straight guy
take on
okay movie
now you guys are waiting for me to say
Judd Apatow is gay I don't know if he's
gay he's married I I like his wife I
think his wife is cute as [__] uh she's
a great actress but why would somebody
take a gay movie I'll tell you what
because they want
the Hollywood people come up to them and
say oh my God you did that movie about
gay people you were so brilliant oh my
God you're so strong and they give you
all those [__] [__] words your
courage undermines every you know you're
sitting there going what courage like I
got a half a million to shoot it no
Curry they paid him he didn't do it for
free he didn't put the money up out of
his pocket so think about why a guy like
me would go you know what I think my
next comedy is going to be a gay comedy
and uh I'm gonna do it on my nah you get
people but just to cut through the chase
the reason why he did it was that so
people could go oh my God you're great
you did a [__] hey you did a a gay
movie the strength of a man and people
backed up
guys like me see right through all that
[__] all this fake I give a [__] I see
right through it I've been there I see
right through it I know how to build it
up and I know how to sell it you know
but these guys they don't do anything
without people saying something to them
like oh my God you're so strong you're
so courageous and they're like I know
get the [__] out of here you want to be
courageous go to a gay bar go in that
[__] tent let them [__] you in the
ass then get back to me then go make a
game movie to see what the ins and outs
are but people didn't buy into it like
who directed it who's the movie by if it
was written by a gay guy yeah like a
real OG gay guy not these new I'm gay
just so I get invited to a [__] party
gay guys because there's a lot of that
[__] going around I know a lot of you
[__] watch bill tomorrow and
you hear how he says that all this
transgender [__] is happening coming out
of California it's not really building
it's picking up momentum in some other
spots but it's not really building and
it's the same thing with these gay
movies like I don't mind them again when
it comes on HBO I watch it you know me I
like to laugh I don't give a [__] but to
think that this movie would bomb what is
wrong with people what is wrong with you
for actually thinking that movie was
gonna go over you got to start small you
got to make like Bath House movies two
guys meeting in a [__] Jacuzzi or
something and then they go suck that
dick with dama and then started back
houses like make a movie I want to see a
gay movie where like cruising have you
ever seen cruising without Pacino no
nobody even knows that movie [__]
exists it came out in 1977. it's about
an undercover cop that goes into the gay
world to [__] see what the [__]
going on you know what that movie got
pulled from the movie theaters
oh you can find it on YouTube or
whatever read it on Wikipedia didn't do
too good
because that was the 70s when you were
gay in the 70s you hit in the [__]
closet that's why they called the
expansion heads coming out of the closet
in the 70s gay people weren't jumping up
and down like they are now when they did
gay pride parades they have to have
protection people throwing rocks from
[__] rooftops and [__] it's not funny
I'm just telling you what the facts were
but in 77 to 76 when cruising came out
it didn't go too [__] well I have to
watch it again it's a dark movie and at
the end of the day it's no Academy Award
winner the thing that saved the movie
The Pacino was in it but
you know
that's what kills me about that they
take these [__] things and then they
get mad at you
for not showing up like that oh well
nobody's shovel you know in today's
world right now what's going on
we have
a war escalating
over there we got like two Wars
escalating didn't the [__] Koreans
just shoot a missile over Japan we got a
bunch of [__] going on over there that's
kind of [__] up to mention that we got
you know prices going up here [__]
covid we still living in this [__]
world that's all [__] up airline
prices are going up everything's going
up but now you want to force this
transgender conversation and gate the
and I appreciate it I love that we're
experiencing different things but it's
not as big as what we're experiencing
do you know what I'm saying like what
we're experiencing as a world right now
as a country is a lot [__] more
important and I've said this on stage
it's more important than me worrying
about your [__] pronoun
it's a lot more important than it really
is so for you guys to make it uh an 80
news story it's not worthy of that as we
shouldn't be talking why should people
not going to see a gay movie be on the
cover of [__] Yahoo or
to make you feel like I was supposed to
feel bad because I didn't go see it or
whatever the [__]
but he [__] let me tell you something
in the real world like I get along you
guys know you've been watching podcasts
for years I get along with a lot of
Comedians and I like a lot of Comedians
and I'm fans of a lot of comedians
you know with Judd I met Judd on the on
the on the set of The Longest Yard I met
Judd I knew who Judd was Judd was a
stand-up [__] comic I had he was on a
young comedian special not a Rodney one
but a regular one with Nick depaolo when
I first started comedy 91
uh Judd was you know he was the
strongest Felicia like Felicia was kind
of big the guy from Boston was big you
know they were kind of big and then when
they disappeared Apple though
I had no idea what the [__] he was doing
nor did I can't you know you're out
there yeah and one day he just showed up
on the side of the longest shot he was
good friends with Adam Sandler and David
Spade and he showed up one day they all
showed up and they were talking
and it was really weird like the third
time I saw Appleton I said hello to him
like hey John how you doing you know you
want to be a nice guy
and he was kind of weird to me like hey
you know whatever and I didn't I didn't
give a [__] I'm smoking dope hanging out
with Michael Irvin we don't give a [__]
about Judd Apple though for
and the next day we're on the set
uh Burt Reynolds is there with the
[__] with Dom DeLuise they're making
spaghetti sauce and [__] and we're
having a great time and also they go Joe
you got to go to your scene
and when I was doing my scene I don't
know if guys I I appreciate people
coming over and trying to help me but
there's sometimes when people come over
and they try to help you that it comes
across wrong and I'm sitting there about
to do a scene with Nelly or something oh
we're gonna do a locker room scene I had
the phone uh we were walking to go over
there
and Judd Apatow just comes up to me and
goes that scene could have been a little
better
what they were laughing I was laughing
it was it was what Adam told me to say
whatever the [__] we're talking about
he's like I felt that scene could have
been better I felt like he was cutting
me down like
like Adam [__] told me to do what I
was doing in that scene what did I do
wrong like out of nowhere like he was
hanging out with Adam you know but it
was yeah he was starting to be a
director I guess
and he said that to me and I I looked at
him for me and I'm like yeah and I'm
like what the [__] are you talking about
you know here my confidence is up do you
know what I'm saying like listen to walk
on that set was scary enough to walk on
that set with Tracy Morgan and Adam and
Chris for the [__] for a guy that
never went to Montreal and [__] was
scary enough once I picked up my
momentum
that got scary I let these [__]
know Uncle Joey wasn't [__] around
and the day they decided that was a dad
threw myself on my back and I'm yelling
you know uh get me a Diet Coke and all
that [__] that's a day they were like
that's it just keep them here just
[__] keep them here that gave me a
boost of [__] confidence like you
know guys I'm I'm the low man on the
totem pole in this movie let's be honest
Nick tutorial was an NYPD Blue me and
Lobo were probably the lowest [__]
two guys on that thing so for them to
sign me and keep me there and do all
this [__] guys I didn't get an ego but
it felt good
that here I am with my peers
and I'm doing my job well considering I
never went to a training academy or I
never hung out with you know Christian
Bale and all that [__] you know it
wasn't bad you know
and this guy comes up to me and I
and like he went away and we did the
[__] like even that scene when I went
into the locker room I went into the
locker room it was just a regular scene
and I'm sitting there
I'm thinking about how I could be better
in the like for young actors or Comics
or whatever when you go into a scene
it's great on paper it's great
but I like to look at it from time to
time
and see how it could be better this is
why his statement [__] me up because I
was like I'm the type of guy that I'll
look at the scene and and
I'll go into a scene when they're
blocking
blocking is when you go into a scene
before you shoot the scene
you're not even in wardrobe yet you just
go in there and they'll they tell you
all the cameras are going to be
where your position is going to be where
he's walking in and they run a couple of
them it doesn't matter about the lines
or anything they just run them to see
how they can't all right move that cam a
little go to a size 16 lens that's what
they do that's yeah the lighting all
that [__] that's what they do in that
scene for some people some people go in
there and they just block and they're
looking around they're cracking jokes
not me when I go on those scenes I'm
looking at everything I'm looking at
what I could feed off of what the [__]
can I feed off all this [__] is fed
material you know when I was watching
Honeymooners the other night Norton
walks in with Ralph they get past
something Norton looks back and it's a
statue of Venus de Milo with no head and
Norton goes boom and he goes Ralph he
must have had a rotten Barber right
that [__]
down and make a [__] joke about
something on the wall Norton on the way
in our Carney came in and he goes Ralph
that's what I'm trying to talk about
when you do that blocking you're looking
for things to feed off they're not just
standing there this what if I just pick
this up and hit myself on the head
anything anything to make the scene
better so I'm sitting there and I'm
analyzing this [__] scene
and I'm like you don't make this scene
better if I was [__] naked
like no shirt on no shorts just like
Serrano Major League
that's what would make this [__]
scene better nobody nobody that was not
in the [__] script guys that was
Uncle Joey fresh out of the [__]
Comedy Store creativity thinking mixing
it with other movies I've seen I went up
to Adam he was talking to two little
white dudes in suits from Paramount and
I go Adam I want to wear a thong for
this one he's like what
I only wear thong for this shot and he
just looked at me and he was he had like
a smile on his face like a devilish like
damn Diaz you're a team player I'm like
I want to play a song and right away one
of the white dudes comes over and he's
like he came with hung we're having
enough problems with ratings all this
[__] Joey's too big it won't look good
Adam's like okay
get this man a [__] jockstrap
get him a jock strap and I [__] strip
naked to add to the scene in the locker
room in front of all those [__]
yoksters all them [__] yoksters
looked at me while I was changing they
saw the Cuban they grow I put my thumb
and I go what and I sat there and guys
this is what I'm saying you gotta work
the scene but back to uh Judd Apatow so
that scene is getting all these laughs
we're having a great time in there
Michael Irvin's throwing his shirt at
[__] uh
Bosworth and all this stuff and then
we're headed to a
a Nelly Nelly released his two albums
that day on 2004 it was like October
September 2004. Nelly released uh
something and something else and we were
all going to the party
and as we're walking out
Chuck came over to me again
well you didn't say nothing to him the
first time right no I don't I wanted I
already had enough problems they knew I
was doing blow on this set at night and
they had sent me to talk to a doctor so
I didn't want to really you know
now the second time he comes up to me is
I'm walking out of that scene which I
thought guys I thought I did a good job
on that scene he came over again and
said something you wish it a wore a
shirt
but by that time I was talking to Nellie
and the other guys I was like [__] this
guy what the [__] you know then all of a
sudden I don't see him again he comes
out for the 40 year old virgin and then
he's doing all these [__] movies
right so
I go back down to the store in
2016 2014 something like that
and I'm you know I'm rekindling myself
because I haven't been at the store in
[__] years I'm just rekindling myself
with all these comics and you know Bill
Burr I got attached to again and Dean
Del Rey and Mark Maron and you know
Whitney Cummings and Eliza I was just
getting in the groove and it was great
and I started hearing that
he would come in
uh
whatever his name is John Apatow would
come in
and he would always just go I want to go
up next you know now what people don't
know about the stories for years that's
what the store was based on
people coming in and going who's up next
Mike is no he's not I'm going up I'm
pulling rank on Mike Mike's a regular
comic I I'm on a TV show you know I'm a
director I pull rank on Mike which I
never liked and all my guys I don't pop
into a lot of comedy clubs today because
you have to respect the headliner okay
at least I do
it's like when I went to see Chasity all
night on Saturday night people come up
to me can we take a picture no
he's the headliner I'm not here to take
that is the most pathetic thing in the
world you know I'm not here to take his
[__] steam I'm gonna sit in the back
and mind my [__] business
so uh yeah he's coming in
uh Leslie's coming in Leslie Jones who
makes me laugh is coming in a lot of
them are coming in and it doesn't bother
me I remember early on one night I was
about to go up and Louis CK bumped me
and I just got my car went home
they were pissed at me these
[__] don't know I just go home
right so I I just I don't have time for
it no more I'm too old to put up with
him you wanna
if you want to put up Lewis instead of
me you made your choice I'll go home I'm
okay with it I don't need you know
so I went home that one time that was it
and then uh
yeah I just wanna I don't play games
like that I just call
I take my reef and I go home
and I don't have nothing against Louis
CK anything
but he could have waited to God and
after me so I was like I'm leaving and
the promoter for him not to do that
knowing my situation is also a scumbag
so I just left
so like 2020 when the pandemic 2020 2019
guys like I've said this and I've never
spoken like this before
six months before the pet from the
pandemic when the pandemic came down
march
16th to go six months back
that was the best I ever was a stand-up
comedian I mean that's how I felt when I
go on stage now I don't feel what I felt
those six months before the pandemic I
was at my Peak as a comic like not as a
peak but
you're there you're in that Groove when
you do stand up for two three years
continuously with no breaks you start
getting in a Groove I had already always
been in the groove at The Comedy Store
you don't want to [__] with me at the
comedy store because The Comedy Store is
where I went in there in 1997 and I
hosted in there every week and I worked
in that original room and the main room
in my first stint I didn't have the main
room down I could tell you that I wasn't
that experienced and I wasn't good
enough don't I don't know I don't know
what it was the 456 but the original
room
I knew how to chop it down like I just
said before about uh when you uh when
you shoot a movie and you block
when you block you get to see the
different things at the room or the
stage has to offer you in The Comedy
Store since listen there's some clubs
that I'm just always money at the
original room the ice house back room
uh Brea the old Brea I could burp and
make you [__] laugh in the old bread
because I knew the walls I knew the
pictures I knew every nook and cranny
the Ice House the regular room is the
easiest room in the country for last
when you throw something out the feeling
you get back at you is [__]
tremendous I I love these rooms but I'm
not good in those rooms because I'm good
in those rooms I'm good in those rooms
because I [__] grew up in those
goddamn rooms so the original room at
the comedy store is my number one home I
could turn my back to the audience in
there and kill looking at the [__]
curtains okay just guys trust me on this
one I would not lie to you guys I I'm
not a big ego type of dude but I know
these things these are just it's just
easy the way Rogan's good up there
forget about how Delia had that [__]
original room going Ali Wong the little
the original room is perfect for comedy
so
Joey get to the [__] story ready so
I'm about to go up at the store and uh
they come up to me
and they go hey man jet Apatow is here
and he wants to bump you and I go that's
not gonna happen
and those two managers just looked at me
and go what like that's not gonna happen
if he wants to go up he'd go up behind
me and that's just fair because the
comedy still had a popping rule that you
could pop in if you were that good of a
comic or credits or you know you won a
TV show that was very popular after
Tommy after Tommy got fired and my man
took it over
they had a rule they don't care if you
come in but just call us
just call us and give us the respect
just call and go hey I'm coming in I'll
be there around 10 30 if I go up at 11
45 uh 10 45 it would be great The Comedy
Store works for you but for you just to
walk in and go I'm going up next
they were all like in shot like hold on
let's say who's up next Joey Diaz Let's
go ask him and I go now
no he's not bumping me he's a director
I'm a comedian big [__] difference
big [__] difference I'm going up
so they went and tell him he's not too
happy
but he won't say nothing to me so as I
walk to the stage I give him a look like
what the [__] do you think guy you know
what I'm saying
and he gives me like this swarmy look
like you know hahaha you know okay
[__]
I was so mad about that him wanting to
bump me whatever listen the best if you
ever want to see me kill a room pissed
me off two minutes before I go to
before I go on stage how do you piss me
off by talking about dumb [__] or your
matching phones or you know your new app
on your computer like I'm about to go up
in front of 300 people and you stupid
[__] back here talking about
some and that's how I get I I go off and
right from there you stupid
[__] are talking about [__]
cell phones back here they're like Joe
you're up next and I'm like [__] you
[__] right there that's where you
don't want me that as a as a as a fan
that's where you want me but as a comic
who's going to go up after me you don't
want me trickling up those steps talking
about you and I'm gonna get over mad
on purpose I'm gonna get overly mad at
you
so I can [__] take that angle like
this you having a matching cell phone
with somebody and you know like showing
each other the data like look does your
phone have that like it gets me mad but
not mad enough to throw you out a window
I get that mad because I know I want to
go upstage like they just lit a little
match and I'm just blowing oxygen on it
but I gotta over over [__] get mad so
when I go up on that stage it's lights
out [__] and on that particular
night it was lights out from the first
minute it was one of those nights I had
to follow Ali Wong I was already
paranoid [__] Ali strong heat I gotta
go up there and I went up there and even
at like the six minute Mark I was out of
breath family what the [__] going on
because I was so anxious so far I had
four [__] Double Cups of espresso in
me in other words I was ready to stab a
[__] and I went up there dog
and I picked that room apart piece by
piece I get [__] emotional thinking
about it piece by piece I just took that
room apart and that one time I looked to
the back and I just saw a Judd like
[__]
his mouth was open and he was look we
made eye contact from the stage and he
looked like a [__] hurricane was
coming his way it was Hurricane Ida and
all of a sudden I [__] got off I
brought him up I know this guy from
Young comedian you know him as a
director I wanted to say [__] this Punk
but I controlled myself and come up to
the stage and as I walked off the stage
I just gave him like a look like
what were you thinking guy
and I walked to get a drink at the bar
like a water
and when I get to the bar I'm not there
three minutes and they're like Joey you
gotta go see this
the managers are like Joey you got to go
see this in comics and I'm like I don't
want to see this [__] [__] and then
Comics go like Joey
you've got to see this
so I ran to the original room I walked
with them I'm like what
John Apatow was on stage he had his
notes out and he was sweating profusely
he had never experienced the Wrath of
the [__] King of Swing
as Joe Rogan likes to put it he had
never experienced that and it was one of
those nights where listen Jesus would
have said no no no no I'm not going
about the joy put some put some milk up
there so he could oh my God it was it
was not good and I waited there until he
walked off the stage and walked down
those stairs
and I just game will look like you dumb
[__] and that was the end if you
check out Judd Apatow he does not do
sets at The Comedy Store no more he goes
to a club called Largo it's a very you
know alternative crowd
I don't know I don't know what the [__]
he did that that's special that special
was null and void after he followed me
if you were there that night you were
like I'm not watching that [__]
special it was not good but I don't feel
great about this guys it's a funny story
and uh
just you know the ego [__] of La that I
[__] hated and I that's the only way
I knew how to fight listen guys whenever
somebody pulled the ego on me or
whatever as a kid I knew two ways how to
fight back Rob them
or make them follow me and [__]
destroy them on stage that's the only
weapons I have that's the only weapons I
have when you would get cute with me
when I was a kid I'd make a mental note
and the first time I had an opportunity
to Rob your [__] house and take your
pound of coke I took it I did not give a
[__] that's how I played If You're Gonna
Play that way I'm gonna play this way
and that's and listen I'm not
that what I'm telling you guys if you're
a young comic watching this this is not
for you
I want you to be part of the show I
never want you to go out of your way to
blow somebody off the stage but as your
[__] comedic advisor if a headliner
gives you a hard time
your goal is to do everything you
[__] can to rock his [__] world
when you walk into a room and a
headliner comes into you and he's been
an extra and he's like telling you like
oh when you go up there mention my name
this way and do this and this and this
and don't curse and don't say the word
[__] and you're like okay
first off the word [__] is the first
[__] word I'm going to say because I
don't know you I don't know some guy
named [__] Joe gags get the [__] out
I don't know you who the [__] are you to
tell me not to say [__] you know it's
it's that [__] so all those people I
used to take them apart I remember doing
Rascals one time while I was I remember
one time I did Rascals with Vic D and it
was a great week
we hadn't met earlier but we had a great
time but one time I did stand up the
week I shot analyzed that I had to work
with Rocky Laporte out of Chicago
foreign
Rocky but for some reason on that week
he was all over me like a cheap suit
I killed the first show on Thursday and
he took me in the back and I'll have to
improvise no more
well you told me not to do dirty
material now I can't improvise no more
and then I went back to the dirty you
can't do dirty material and finally I
got him on a [__] on Friday and I go
listen I'm doing what the [__] I want
the mem the head dude the guy me and Vic
were talking about
I brought him in I got town when you
book a headlining gig
if I come out here and blow sparklers
out of my [__] for 45 minutes you got
to figure out a way to follow me if not
don't take the headlining gig don't take
it
and we settled that he got mad at me I
don't think he'll ever talk to me again
but
Que Sera Sera [__] you know what I'm
saying
it's Thursday you bad [__] I
watched uh
my brother George sent me a video of the
other day and I saw it on Twitter some
girl retweeted of Tom Segura and Rogan
talking about me the other day about
but my brother was like that's a [__]
hilarious story
you don't work Sundays
and I'm like listen guys
it's I I had to sell it to those guys
those guys would not take my [__]
words for years
I'm an old school guy I work seven days
a week I don't give a [__] about nothing
but
have you ever done stand up on a Sunday
night
it's not good
it's good if they call me from Uncle
Vinnie's or the stress Factory and say
Joey can you film on a Sunday night I'll
be more than happy to go over that I'll
be more than happy to go over there and
do 45 minutes just to bail them out but
if you tell me you want me to come to
your town and work a Sunday that's not
happening that's never gonna happen I
started comedy in 1991.
and by 93 I worked every [__] Sunday
I I know where I worked on Sundays it
was brutal
the comedy show followed a line dancing
show okay so they would go from achy
breaky heart to welcome to Comedy Night
on a [__] Sunday in some bum [__]
redneck town in Colorado I did it every
Sunday
when you get into comedy
be quiet and they tell you Thursday you
know Tuesday through Sunday you take
them and you take them so from 91 to 97
I think
I was all in you know by 97 98 I was
going on the road I was going on the
road
three times a month you know by 2000 I
was on the road either with Rogan on my
own and I'll never forget one
I think it was like 99. I hadn't met
Terry yet and
I was at the Dallas Improv
Addison Improv great great [__] club
I like that town I've always liked that
town but I'm on this particular Sunday
I [__] woke up
you know you get up on a Sunday you're a
little hungover from at that time I was
still hungover
you know you get up you you smoke a few
cigarettes you drink a cup of coffee
maybe you eat some breakfast at that
time they didn't have a [__]
breakfast in the hotel lobby they had
like a a Danish or something like that
but it wasn't uh you know
and you either go to the gym you eat
lunch and then you wait till [__]
eight o'clock to do your show
that's Sundays guys you wait all day to
do a show on [__] Sunday yeah you
watch football it's not bad you go to I
used to go to Chuck and jive a little
seafood gumbo bar and watch the game
some guy gave me Dallas tickets once but
it was on this particular Sunday that I
went back to the hotel
gotcha would went to do the show and I'm
like
what the [__]
I walk in then there's 60 [__] people
let me tell you something
if you live in Dallas
and you go to a comedy show on Sunday
especially in the winter time
that I don't want to perform for you
people
like it got to the point where I didn't
want to perform for them
because they were goofy who goes on the
Sunday night to see comedy we were here
all [__] weekend you could have came
but tonight
tonight is when you want to come see
comedy and there was 60 or 50 [__]
people
I don't forget when that guy gave me the
check tray blue great guy gave me the
check that Sunday I go he goes I want to
book you again for 90 days because when
you're a feature you can go to a club
back and forth and I said yeah and I
said to him I'm not working Sunday
though and he was like but but what am I
gonna do you gotta work Sunday so a lot
of clubs when I made up my mind that I
wasn't working Sundays
a lot of clubs wouldn't hire me and I
didn't give a [__]
and then I started pulling the Louis
Lamour I said [__] now [__] with them
after I got like Mad TV
and maybe like analyze that I started
using my head I started going yeah I
work Wednesday through Sunday absolutely
when the week came I would call him
Tuesday and go hey man I'm flying in
tomorrow but I can't I already had him
over a barrel
I already have them over a barrel
they're stuck they're not gonna say
don't come I would say I can't where I
gotta leave Sunday if you get a
replacement
okay I get it you're doing a movie I did
that I pulled that [__] line for
years and then Joe would do Sundays for
some reason Joe would go to Florida and
do Friday Saturday Sunday and I would
get furious I would [__] yell at him
before the trip while we were coming
home right because you have to come home
on Monday
Monday sucks dick to fly and these
[__] are flying out at one so
you're not getting back home till five
in the afternoon that's your whole day I
don't have time for that [__] even when
I was 38 I didn't have time for that
[__] so I decided I'm not doing [__]
Sundays no more and I told Joe and I
told everybody right and they thought I
was [__] with them
you know how many times I left Joe in
the city and left on a Sunday
and he wouldn't talk to me for two or
three weeks
I would just leave on a Sunday morning
Joey where are you I had to leave
brother I told you I don't work Sundays
they could not believe it
they could not believe it I still
remember being on a plane with Joe and
him [__] like yelling at me like Joey
what the [__] Amigo listen
because he got married way before I did
like he was with her way before I you
know like he was starting to make things
happen I was still dating Terry and he
was like already like moving her in so I
told him one [__] one day you're gonna
have [__] kids and you're not gonna
work Sunday
and he thought about him within like a
year he knew he wasn't going to get me
to work Sundays they all knew and I
still remember sitting times to grow it
down and going listen you [__]
if you work a Sunday I'm gonna [__]
stab you you burnt all ears do not work
Sundays because then that's going to
open up the [__] floodgates for us
and then be like I don't mind working so
they know you're not gonna work [__]
Sundays all of them I yelled at all of
them till they awkward Sundays and that
was the end of it I would do Sundays at
the store if I had to like if Melo had a
show or something
and guys just so you know I was doing
this as a feature act this was way
before The Longest Yard this was way
before the pipe this is 10 15 years
before the podcast I just decided one
day I'm not doing it I don't give a [__]
I'd rather not work than have to work a
Sunday it's the Lord's Day [__]
and on the Lord's day God created Black
Sabbath so take that to the
[__] bank I love you
[__] stay black say a prayer for
uh Ralphie and uh listen I do the
podcast while I'm sick of talking now
that's it some of them will be two hours
I might do a 30 minute podcast next week
but no we'll be back to normal next week
sorry about this week with the [__]
pilot and shooting next week I shoot
Thursday so it won't affect you guys
hopefully I'll see you [__]
Saturday night in the city Lee's coming
down I got Kim condom and I got my girl
Sarah Wayne check stay black
have a great weekend and I'll see you
[__] Monday morning Tip Top
Magoo and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors
all right I want to thank you guys for
putting up with my [__] today the joint
is brought to you by manscape listen
fall is here and that bush is getting
bigger it's time to shave that thing
make that pogo stick look like a [__]
like a flagpole
listen manscape is tremendous it creams
trims you up cleans you up they got so
many great products over there from the
[__] uh the stuff you put on your
balls to unwrinkle your nut sack to the
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer the weed
whacker nose and ear trimmer it's all
waterproof and you can shave in the
shower and even has a little LED light
so you don't cut your dick off by
mistake manscape is even throwing in two
free gifts to that package the manscape
boxes and the shed travel bag
take a look at the shears 2.0 that
luxury nail grooming kit it includes
stainless steel nail cutters tweezers
and grooming scissors no more scratching
your lady in bed with those [__] feet
now get 20 off and free shipping with
Coach Joey at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with code Joey at
manscape.com go with manscape oh trim
the [__] leaves out of your ears and
all that stuff listen holiday season is
coming upon us that means people gonna
start mailing [__] you don't want to be
in the [__] line at the post office
stuck all the time smelling stinky
[__] people that's why we got
stamps.com they got everything you need
to make your life easy it's virtual 24 7
post office no lines no traffic no
hassle how easy is stamps.com [__]
easy I've been doing it for 12 years
with my wife you got you get discounts
uh at the post office and UPS shipping
Services right from your a computer and
you're going to save 30 off USPS rates
and over 86 percent off UPS all you need
is your regular computer and printer no
special supplies or equipment print
official postage for any letter any
package anywhere get ahead of the
holiday chaos and get started with
stamps.com you sign up with promo code
Joey for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial free postage and a free
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone on the top page and enter
code Joey and last but not least is my
family DraftKings the best tonight we
got a tremendous [__] game and
DraftKings is there to cover it we're
also picking up with the baseball
playoffs which is always exciting you
got the UPS you got college football I
mean this is the season to have [__]
fun with DraftKings they're the official
sports betting partner in the NFL and
what that doing this put five dollars on
any team to win even if your team loses
they're gonna get 200 and free bets and
you can boost your winnings with the
same game parlays those things are so
[__] great that DraftKings is letting
you throw down one stepped up same game
Paulie a day all season long so starts
with you download the draftkingsport
forget use promo code Joey to get 200
and free bets if your team wins when you
place five dollars on any football team
that's coach Joey only at DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
part of the NFL minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes with details DraftKings now go win
some [__] money you Savages I
want to thank DraftKings I want to thank
stamps.com manscape better help I want
to thank yous all for being here and
supporting us and you guys for having
our back stay black and we'll see you
[__] Monday morning Tip Top Magoo
you know